I seem fun the diary of Jen Kirkman
podcast episode 158 the Thanksgiving
episode look I brought a Thanksgiving
looking thing to put here we are live
video streaming now don't you worry if
you're like anyone I went this hill in
video you suck you don't listen this is
a podcast I've been doing it for years
sometimes I do a live version from the
studio if you aren't familiar with it
you will hate this so just log off now
and save your comments but if you are a
fan of the show and you will you should
be a fan of the show it is me doing a
silver podcast every week about things
going on in my life mostly a little bit
what's going on the world but I seem fun
is a thing I came up with years ago
because the things I've done in show
business make me seem fun the Chelsea
Handler's show drunk history I am NOT
that person in real life I am NOT drunk
and falling down all the time I am NOT
talking about Lindsay Lohan although I
do want to talk about her refugee camp
for I mean her um she's got a nightclub
for Refugees and I don't even understand
anyway but it is me Jen Kirkman a
neurotic overthinking feeling person of
42 years you don't look 42 off
that's not a compliment you can enjoy my
mug that says rich the joke of it
is that the money sign is not covering
up the swear at Jen Kirkman calm go to
the merch page alright that's a private
joke in the podcast if even if it isn't
why wouldn't you want a mug that says
rich I think it's fantastic so I'm
drinking water here we are
it is our Thanksgiving episode I am
thankful for the opting Comedy Network
for Bill burr and al Madrigal asking me
to be a part of it and all the wonderful
people that that that work so hard on
all of our podcasts like Mike and
Britain and and Aaron and here we are
sorry I got it I got a tweet I got
excited here we are doing it up so oh
I've got exciting announcement Friday is
Black Friday you can get I'm doing my
annual fourth annual always sold out jen
kirkman dysfunctional comedy show at the
Hollywood improv December 3rd a bunch of
comedians you know and love Laurie kill
Martin Eddie Pepitone Brooke van
poppelen Solomon Giorgio o telling
hilarious stories but they're also a
little dark and we're doing this sort of
anti holiday festive thing but it's also
festive it's a little it's the best of
both worlds and won't make you feel bad
if you hate the holidays and if you like
the holidays you won't be like why are
these guys being all cynical now there's
a corporate party of 50 people coming
and it's making me my pants because
I'm assuming they're all Trump
supporters and I'm afraid they're not
going to like the show so I need the
fans to come out in full effect because
50 is only like not even a third of the
audience it's 300 so if I get 250 of all
you good people so what I've done for
you and the tickets are 20 bucks each
but a portion of the proceeds goes to
the LA Food Bank so you can feed the
hungry and if you bring a pair of
child's pajamas or a children's book
brand new I will donate them for you you
don't have to do a thing to the pajama
program and all that info is on Jen
Kirkman com click on tour dates but my
point is Friday Black Friday this Friday
tickets are two-for-one if you go to my
website again Jen Kirkman com click on
tour dates click the link or go to
improv comm if you want to circle
through Hollywood and then pick the
right night whatever and the tickets are
two-for-one if you put Black Friday all
caps in the offer coats so you and a
friend or a partner I don't know your
status can come for $20 for the two of
us and your you know you dip it in the
charity a little bit it don't say chip
and then but that's ok I want to be
charitable to you because I will make my
own donation to the LA Food Bank after
the show I will not declare that I'm
gonna match it because I don't know how
much we're gonna make and let's not go
crazy I give to a lot of charities this
time of year but if you get the
two-for-one tickets maybe you bring a
book with you or something so that's
just for one day only
Friday Black Friday set your calendars
or write it down okay I'm hearing my
Netflix special is gonna be airing like
sooner than like sometime in
January I don't know the exact date yet
I'm probably shouldn't even say what I
just said but I will be going on a tour
in September tour dates have changed a
little bit since Kurt recent events so
uh forgive me if you don't see your city
on the list but a girl's got to not be
afraid to drive through some areas okay
so that's it I think that's all be Oh
Sketchfest
San Francisco Sketchfest I will be
coming back to San Francisco in January
for the sketch fest one-night-only I'm
just doing a live I seem fun at the
Swedish American Hall so that is on sale
now also on my website Jen Kirkman comm
click tour dates and then you won't see
me anywhere until September so you want
to hear some random facts about
Thanksgiving I'm gonna give them to you
and I know I know I know before all you
young people write me as though I
haven't been alive longer than
you I've read Howard Zinn I know I know
Thanksgiving we stole we saw this
country not on that exact day I
understand so I left the price tag on I
understand it's a white person's holiday
and it's about oppression I get it but
are you gonna sit home and not do
anything maybe you are is that the right
reason is that the reason though I know
a lot of people are not going to
celebrate Thanksgiving with their
families this year because of
aforementioned elections and such we'll
talk about that later in the episode but
let's start fun before we get frenzied
okay but in the look there's a thing
called Thanksgiving in it's
Thursday I don't know what you want me
to do undo it get in the Town Square I
look at I know I know what it's built on
with all that being said here's some fun
things about Thanksgiving the night
before Thanksgiving is the biggest
drinking night of the year even bigger
than st. Patrick's Day or New Year's Eve
which is totally true
I think people usually go home to their
hometowns the
get together with their old friends they
get up and then the next day is
your hangover recovery day and what
better way to recover from a hangover
than to have to do jack and eat
like carbs all day long so that makes
sense to me I probably won't be drinking
the night before Thanksgiving this year
I don't have a event like that planned
still trying to not overdo it or drink a
lot my voice has been so good I I don't
want to do anything to it up will
you guys be drinking producer Mike Aaron
what's your drink of choice I saw you
with a clear liquid at The Improv lab
you like a gin and tonic what do you
what do you like to drink Jack and Coke
Aaron do you drink cuz your stomach okay
I mean I know that we had bonded over
what did we get upper endoscopy what do
you enjoy a faux alcohol do you drink
water will you be breathing air tomorrow
night and more than usual probably a lot
of hot air coming out as I'm yelling at
family members oh you're gonna be with
your family yeah oh my lord
mmm well congrats to you for doing it
without alcohol and and it's actually
better to do it without alcohol because
feelings get pretty up the
average American will consume 4500
calories on Thanksgiving Day that
doesn't seem like a lot like to 2500
2000 2500 is normal for a male to eat in
a day so you're only eating 2,000 more
under not doesn't seem right three
thousand for the meal and 1500 for
snacking a danam that doesn't so long
before the pilgrims Native Hawaiians
celebrated the longest Thanksgiving in
the world called Makahiki which lasts
for four months approximately from
November through February during this
time both work and war are forbidden I
can get behind that I suppose they're
not doing that anymore but I would like
to celebrate maka he
all the time so President Jefferson
called Thanksgiving the most ridiculous
idea ever conceived he was not a fan of
it
George Washington proclaimed the first
Thanksgiving
despite being first proclaimed by George
George Washington in 1789 Jefferson
believed that a national day of
Thanksgiving was not consistent with the
principle of separation of church and
state oh my god except for the slavery
bring back the founding fathers
and the oppression towards women isn't
it amazing that we live in a country now
where I'm like okay I know they had
slaves and and women couldn't take part
in the government but they had more
intellectual ideas than President Elect
okay he refused to recognize the holiday
in any of the eight years in which he
was president he wrote everyone must act
according to the dictates of his own
reason and mine tells me that civil
powers alone have been given to the
President of the United States and no
authority to direct the religious
exercises of his constituents for the
record presidents Andrew Jackson and
Zachary Taylor refused to issue
Thanksgiving Day proclamations during
their administration's - ah so great so
I have an article here this is called
what really happened on Thanksgiving
it's from a website called Indian County
and don't worry it's not gonna be all
doom and gloom you know white people who
get upset it's just a little more
factual so when you hear about the
Pilgrims and the Indians harmoniously
sharing the first Thanksgiving meal in
1621 the Indians referred to so
generically are the ancestors of the
contemporary members of the Wampanoag
nation is it Wampanoag or wampum nog I
think it is - it's spelled no egg you
but you never know what those Spelling's
they go they do the full syllables they
do that okay yeah no silent O's for the
Indian nation of the Wampanoag nation as
the story commonly goes the pilgrims who
sailed from England on the Mayflower and
landed at what became Plymouth
Massachusetts in 1620 had a good harvest
the next year so Plymouth Governor
William Bradford organized a feast to
celebrate the harvest and invited a
group of Native American allies
including the Wampanoag Chief Massasoit
to the party the feast let I love that
they're allies we owe their allies to
the people that invaded their land they
shouldn't have to be anyone's ally
anyway
the fees lasted three days and according
to chronicler Edward Winslow
Bradford sent four men on a fouling
mission to prepare for the feast and the
Wampanoag guests brought five deer to
the party I'm rolling five deers deep at
this party and ever since then the story
goes Americans have celebrated
Thanksgiving on the fourth Thursday of
November not exactly
Ramona Peters the Mashpee Wampanoag
tribes tribal historic preservation
officer told Indian country today Media
Network in a conversation on the day
before Thanksgiving in 2012 391 years
since that first mythological
Thanksgiving the question was we know
we're taught in the mainstream media and
schools we know that's made up what's
the Wampanoag version she said yeah it
was made up it was Abraham Lincoln who
used the theme of Pilgrims and Indians
eating happily together he was trying to
calm things down during the Civil War
when people were divided it was like a
nice unity story so this person added it
was a political thing yes it was public
relations it's kind of genius in a way
to get people to sit down and eat dinner
together families were divided during
the Civil War it's sort of like today
where President Obama is on the campaign
trail literally at times just ripping
loose you know like come on man and just
making fun of Trump and then now he's
gonna sit and shake that
guy's hand that didn't think he was born
in this country he's got to be kind of
this
and he's like let's just now everyone
calm down let's see how he's gonna do
and we're all in the streets like we
already know and he's gonna do
everyone's losing their but it's
been explained to me that not everyone
can act like a little commie like me
Obama cannot declare this is an
emergency this man is unfit the world
will go into unrest now I I'm my point
of view is let it happen it's already
there just just say no I can't do this
it's the Elizabeth Mitt Romney and one
maybe of course we're showing him around
Hillary obviously it was assumed she won
but forgot that the Russians and the FBI
hacked it to make it look like he won by
one percentage point in every state that
he won in which is strange math I've
been reading about it I love that people
go you just think they cheated cuz your
son didn't win I don't have a side I
don't care who the listen to me my
side is not hatred and and anyone who's
in bed with the Russians I mean were you
guys alive in the 80s oh you weren't
take it from the grown-ups the Russians
hack that's what they do that's
what they do they oh my god it's not
crazy to believe the mainstream news
which says that let's attack the
election I'm not crazy for reading the
goddamn news I'm sorry it's not written
on jarring white type with a black
background that's a website you're
reading of a neo-nazi what are you
reading the liberal New York Times
anyway so as we all sit together on
Thanksgiving we realized that we cannot
be civilized sometimes in a divided time
that's why some of us will not be
joining our now let me finish reading
this I will be not joining my family
this Thanksgiving nothing to do with
senior Trump a bad hombre numero uno I
usually make a decision between
Christmas or Thanksgiving to fly home to
Boston and spend thousands of dollars on
people that frankly never spend the
money to come see me so I said this year
I'm gonna go home
during the month of December not
Christmas and have some gifts and get on
my way but I was never going home for
Thanksgiving some years I have there was
one year recently I did and that's
because I was living in New York for two
months November through January in 2014
and it was easy to take the old Amtrak
from Penn Station to Boston and I had
Thanksgiving with my family I think my
family would rather not deal with the
whole Thanksgiving thing my parents are
older now they like to go to a
restaurant my sister likes to do a
friendsgiving with her friends I hate
that the media figured out the people
were doing that because now they're like
friends giving it it's so gross and then
friends giving which used to just be
Thanksgiving for people who didn't see
their families and just had it with
their friends now it's a whole other
holiday the week before it's obnoxious
it's obnoxious that's just called having
dinner with your friends so anyway
that's all I'm not going home nothing to
do with with that the election I've said
that 50 times I am meeting my
boyfriend's mother for the first time on
Thanksgiving which the reason it's not a
big deal and I'll get back to the
article this is why you love I seem fun
because it's really about my life the
reason it's on a big deal is because my
because Jake has no family he has a
mother and a father and his father's not
around and so he has a mother who lives
in Los Angeles and that to me is the
jackpot
someone with literally and I mean
literally no extended family now I'm
sure these people exist I don't need to
get into his family history on my
podcast if he wants to talk about it he
can do an announcement to the American
people but to not have to meet anyone
else's family is such a joy at my age I
am tired I've met so many families so
many lovely people I've been in
relationships with but I am family'd out
I don't want to I don't want to talk to
anyone's uncle anymore and so it's a joy
and so we'll be spending with his mom
but she's not as I've been told she's
not like a mom mom she's not gonna be up
my business like
why are you using that pan when we're
not cooking anyway we're ordering in
Thanksgiving food that's already been
cooked but as you know I was in a
marriage and my mother-in-law was one of
the nicest people I've ever met and I
agree with her politics and I liked her
style in a way I liked the way she lived
her life but she was
I just wasn't just I'm I up was
information time in married today ma'am
I shouldn't uh it just wasn't the right
time my life to have a mother-in-law up
my potox and there was a lot of talking
about what pans I should have and I
don't want to think about pans ever I
want to be a little more interesting
than thinking about pans and then all I
do is look on Instagram and Pinterest
and put like home decor pins on a board
but that's different but I don't bore
you the conversation about pans except
on this podcast so I forgot I
have to buy some Tupperware does not a
joke that it's me maybe I have to write
myself a note anyway I remember one time
my mother-in-law said to me when I was
visiting over Christmas what are you
gonna do with your hiatus that sort of
showbusiness people called vacation I
was writing on a popular television show
at the time and we had two weeks off I
said well I'm gonna work on some other
stuff on my own and I'm probably just
gonna watch movies and she said you
might get into baking no I might not I
definitely won't get into baking and she
kept saying you might though that's a
good way to relax not for someone who
hates baking doesn't want to go to the
grocery store carry stuff home dirty
things and clean them and then no not
baking thank you though for the
suggestion of a thing I'll never do so
I'm really thankful this holiday that I
and with someone who doesn't have a
family I thought I'd hit the jackpot now
let's go back in the time machine I
thought I'd hit the jackpot last year
when I was dating a guy whose mother was
dead and this is evil to say but I had
specifically wished for that
if you watch my 2015 Netflix special I
sort of put it out there in the universe
i secret at it
but I thought someone with a dead mom
would be ideal because then that mother
could not get in my business and be like
why don't you have kids or what are you
getting married
and it turns out when someone's mother
has passed and this person doesn't have
their life together all they talk about
is their mother and their mother is a
perfect person who never told them to
pick up their socks or anything and so
they don't know how to be in a
relationship with women so do not wish
or be careful what you wish for you
might get it but a year ago this time I
was with my Australian ex
or he wasn't my ex at the time and I was
so anxious I don't know how to describe
it I thought it was the anxiety of being
in a long-distance relationship which
causes so much anxiety especially when
you're on the other side of the world
and you only have a few waking hours
that you're kind of in the same time
zone when you can speak and I don't mean
I didn't trust him like cheating I just
didn't trust him I don't know what it
was I just didn't trust that anything he
said was real after a while like his
plans I'm gonna move here I'm gonna do
this I just I just went I caught I
caught a fish I should have throw him
back you know you know when you catch a
fish and you know take it home and cook
it and then some you just throw back I
should have thrown it back and I didn't
and he came to visit me the week of
Thanksgiving not because it was
Thanksgiving but it just worked out that
way and I just I just knew that I
something is wrong here something was
wrong and he didn't really understand my
podcast and though that was something
that not really bothered me but
sometimes you would just walk in the
house when I was taping it and I would
make him get on the mic and you thought
it was weird and just like Madonna and
Morin Beatty and truth or dare you know
when the person doesn't want to get on
the camera that they're gonna leave and
you'll be there with your backup dancers
now I don't have any backup dancers so
when we broke up I had to get through it
on my own but God I knew in my heart
that something wasn't right and I was
feeling anxious and I was feeling
anxiety all the time in that feeling if
you will allow me to go spiritual for a
minute when you're doing your will vs.
the will of what should be sometimes you
feel tight like you're being like a vise
you're just being squeezed and
I knew something wasn't right but I
couldn't tell well is that that just the
long distance or is that him and it was
him and me it was not he is not he is
not a mature person who knows how to be
in a relationship I doubt I'm sure he's
in one now or something but I don't
think he's ever gonna get that part of
his life together you know those people
you might have him in your life whether
for them its drinking or getting a job
you're just like that's not gonna happen
for you he is just not well he is a kind
of just a nomad kind of a nowhere or
whatever nowhere man if that makes sense
it's not a bad person at all but I do
not need to be friends with him is where
I've landed and we have not been friends
we've not spoken and at least over six
months and not an angry way just not I
don't recognize him as a person that
could be in my life but what a
difference a year makes I think I knew
last year as I was hanging out with my
best friend Jake all the time I was like
I got a what's going on and so it
seems normal and lovely to be back with
my ex and technically we've been
together over Thanksgivings before but
we are either living in different places
or we had other plans so we never
combined them so this would be the first
one that we combined and I I think we've
hung out on Thanksgiving before that's
not true oh I'll tell you guys this
story so when my ex and I were dating
before from roughly December 2011 to
January 2014 was always an open thing
you know keep it casual don't commit
even though that's all I wanted to do
but I was having some problems and so
you know we never did the normal thing
that couples do so there's one
Thanksgiving
he was like I'm just gonna go to my
mom's house she's having some friends
over of hers and I said that's great I'm
gonna go to a friend's house and I went
to a friend's house who didn't have
Thanksgiving food and I didn't know that
I said to my friend should I bring
anything and they were like now that's
fine and I I I don't know how to discuss
it because the food was incredible
but it wasn't Thanksgiving food now I'm
a vegetarian I don't eat meat
and I what I call cheating vegan I don't
eat dairy and it's but I do eat fish
sometimes for reasons so but for me I
just mainly just pretty much know that
there's no meat and mostly no dairy or
no dairy but on Thanksgiving if I'm
going to your house and you've got
mashed potatoes that you made with
butter yeah yeah yeah I'm eating that
I'm eatin it unless I have a performance
that night the dairy with my voice
so I'm sort of like you know I'll do
whatever I want on Thanksgiving although
I never want to eat turkey it's it's
gross
no offense so I get to my friends house
and it's kale salad and I'm a health nut
I like kale I'm gonna tease Hollywood
liberals it like scale but I like it in
a smoothie I don't have to look at it
just hide that kale for me I don't like
it
i I've I've eaten it I'll weed it again
I don't like it
my friend made kale and then some kind
of rice thing and then some kind of like
healthy boiled fish I don't know what
was happening and I wanted to cry and I
thought I was in a deep denial like
maybe these are appetizers as we sat at
the table and toasted Happy Thanksgiving
and I was like this isn't an appetizer
and and I I I still don't have words for
it and I went home early and I sat on my
couch in a daze
I just couldn't believe what had
happened to my life and at Jake at the
time my non boyfriend boyfriend said I
have leftovers from what my mom made and
I was like oh god please
and he brought over the cranberry sauce
the stuffing the mashed potatoes all the
fixings and I just ate it out of
Tupperware and I was like this the best
so that was the only time we spent
Thanksgiving together and so we will be
doing it right this time
but yeah last year I love don't you love
if your life is better in some ways than
it was a year ago don't you sometimes
love just thinking about it like God
what was and I got through it I got
through it you guys don't give up a year
can make such a difference like sort of
how last year was
amazing and this year we elected Trump
okay so let's keep reading about the
Wampanoags so here's what the god what's
this woman's Ramona Peters the Mashpee
Wampanoag tribes tribal historic
preservation officer here's what she
says really happened
we made a treaty the leader of our
nation at the time I like how she's
talking like she was there like I've
lived 300 years I did it by uh you know
just eating small meals and walking on
the leader of our nation at the time
yellow feather Oh Smith meek queen
Massasoit 'it made a treaty with John
Carver the first governor of the colony
they elected an official while they were
still on the boat they had their charter
they were still under the jurisdiction
of the King of England at least that's
what they told us so they couldn't make
a treaty for a boatload of people so
they made a treaty between two nations
England and the Wampanoag nation the
treaty basically said that we the
Indians would let them be there and we
would protect them against any enemies
and they would protect us from any of
ours it was basically an I'll watch your
back you watch mine agreement later we
collaborated on jurisdictions in
creating a system so that we could live
together
what's the mash pian of the 1621 meal
you've probably heard the story of how
Squanto assisted in the planting of corn
so this was their first successful
harvest and they were celebrating that
harvest and planning a day of their own
Thanksgiving and it's kind of like what
some of the Arab nations do when they
celebrate by shooting guns in the air so
this is what was going on for on over in
Plymouth they were shooting guns and
cannons as a celebration which alerted
us because we didn't know who they were
shooting at America from the
beginning so Massasoit gathered up some
90 warriors and showed up at Plymouth
prepared to engage if that's what was
happening if they were taking any of our
people they didn't know it was a
fact-finding mission when they arrived
it was explained through a translator
that they were selling
the harvest so we decided to make sure
we decided to stay and make sure that
was true because we'd seen in other
landings Captain John Smith even the
Vikings had been here we just wanted to
make sure so we decided to camp nearby
for a few days during those few days the
men went out to hunt and gather food
deer ducks geese and fish
imagine you show up to her Thanksgiving
someone just like here's a geese plop
you take the feathers out yourself there
are 90 men here and at the time I think
there are only 23 survivors of that boat
the Mayflower so you can imagine the
fear you have armed natives who are
camping nearby and the colonists were
always vulnerable to the new land new
creatures even the trees there were no
such trees in England at that time
people forgot that they had just landed
here and this coastline looked a very
different from what it looks like now
and their culture new foods they were
afraid to eat a lot of things all cooked
so they were very vulnerable and we did
protect them not just support them we
protected them you can see throughout
their journals that they were always
nervous and unfortunately when they were
nervous they were very aggressive Oh
white people I'm scared here my gun Wow
so the pilgrims didn't invite the
whompin no eggs to sit down and eat
turkey and drink dinner she laughs haha
no let's just put it this way people did
eat together
it was our homeland in our territory and
we walked all through their villages all
the time the difference is how they
behaved how they ate how they prepared
things that was a lot for both cultures
to work with each other but in those
days it was sort of like today when you
go out on the boat in the open sea and
you see another boat and everyone's
waving and very friendly it's because
they're vulnerable and need to rely on
each other if something happens in those
days the English really needed to rely
on us and yes they were polite as best
they could be but they regarded us as
savages nonetheless so the person asked
so you did eat together sometimes but
not at the legendary Thanksgiving meal
she says no we were there for days again
I love how she's acting like she was
there and this is another thing we give
thanks more than once a year in formal
ceremony for different reasons for the
corn Thanksgiving for the arrival of
certain fish species whales the first
snow our new year in May there are so
many ceremonies and I think most
cultures have similar traditions it's
not a foreign concept and I think human
beings who recognize greater spirit than
they than them would have to say thank
you in some formal way so what are the
Mashpee Wampanoag is taught about
Thanksgiving now most of us are taught
about the friendly Indians and the
friendly pilgrims and people sitting
down and eating together they don't
really go into any depth about the
period and what it was like in 1620
there was always focus on food because
people had to work hard to go out and
forage for food not the way it is now
there's another element that needs to be
noted as well the Puritans believed in
Jehovah and they were listening for
Jehovah's directions on a daily basis
and trying to figure out what would
please their God
so for Americans for the most part
there's a Christian element to
Thanksgiving so formal prayer and some
families will go around the table and
ask what you're thankful for this year
in Mashpee families we make offerings of
tobacco
now that sounds fun for traditionalists
we give thanks to our first mother our
human mother and a mother earth Earth
ain't no woman here's my gun Wow then
because there is no real time you
embrace your hands thanks and passing
them into the tobacco without wait am i
speaking English anymore then because
there's no real time to it you embrace
your thanks and passing them into the
tobacco without necessarily speaking out
loud but to actually give your mind and
spirit together thankful for so many
things
unfortunately because we're trapped in
this cash economy in this 9 to 5 we
can't spend the normal amount of time on
ceremonies which would last for days for
proper Thanksgiving well that's the real
Thanksgiving a comment section someone
wrote this is so racist against white
people I can't I can't I
you goddamn tell a story in a paper
about a tribe that lived here before
white people came and then you're just
very diplomatic lishi described what the
white people were like they were nerve
the guns that's right yes against what
I'm sorry I'm doing a southern accent if
you don't want to be known like that
don't vote for Trump in the next
election and I won't call you racist or
go back in time and don't be fighting
the north because you want slaves I know
not all not all anything so let's have
some memories about my Nana ma I always
loved Thanksgiving because it was a
special treat when my Nana Jeanette as
we called her my mom's mom who was a
widow for 39 years of her life she was
not unhappy about it thank you very much
didn't need your pity she's no longer
with us she grew to not love her dead
husband more and more every year so she
would come visit and we would take walks
to a place called the little red store I
mean it sounds like I was born in the
20s but it is now and then it became
Hazel's bakery which were like well hang
on a minute hoses hazel noir bakery this
is way too corporate and now
it's a 7-eleven so we went to the little
red store and we would take a walk and
it was always the morning before
Thanksgiving and she would buy me at
Donuts and she would let me eat one on
the walk home without telling my mom and
then she would just tell me stories all
kinds of fucked-up things that probably
shouldn't tell a child but you know
Jesus is coming and the end of the world
and her husband wasn't a nice man and
she didn't love him and she went on a
date one time my Nana someone said to
her you need to go on a date she told me
this when I was about 12 years old we
were taking our walk back from the
little red store and a nice crisp fall
day back in Massachusetts in God what
this would be 1986 and she said that
some man asked her out on a date and
then she said yes and she assumed they
would be going out at night going to
dinner and then he said do you want to
go to church together one morning and
she was like that's on a date
Church and he's like no we'll go to
breakfast before she was like all right
and he took her to McDonald's and she
was pissed my name is not some fancy
lady she was a very very
of modest means if any means kept her
money in tin foil and wrapped it up like
a sandwich and put it in the bottom
drawer of your stove that you don't even
know you have you young you Millennials
in your first apartments go go to the
stove there's a drawer under there and
that's where if you were an old woman
you would put your pots and pans and
then your money because she thought the
robbers would never look there and she
was right not that I would never
robbed her house we never got to test
that theory but I believe they wouldn't
have looked there and so anyway she was
like can you not piss on my leg and tell
me it's raining or that's something the
expression doesn't whatever the
expression is for someone taking to
McDonald's and you're super bummed about
it you're like oh the worst thing if
you're gonna go get pancakes just go to
IHOP or Denny's it's a little more
expensive than McDonald's but let
someone know you care because the minute
you have to open up syrup from a plastic
thing and you're in you're in a
restaurant that's not even how they do
it to go that's how they do it to in
when you sit down
that's just like a you that guy
thought he was gonna get laid I mean I
don't think they were having sex but
anyway so my Nana would tell me stories
like that and then things she loved the
city of Atlantis she was obsessed with
that and the Bermuda Triangle all kinds
of weird conspiracies my Nana was into
and then we'd go home we'd read The
Enquirer together and we would watch
television she had a crush my
grandmother had a crush on Rob Reiner
his character meet head-on on the family
I think my and my mom is a crush on John
Lennon my mom and my Nana have a real
thing for hippies you wouldn't know it
from my mom's politics as of late but
they have a real thing for hippies they
my Nana would go oh that meathead is so
sexy oh that's my mom's impression
whatever was my Nana too I guess and I
was always uncomfortable with my Nana
talking about anyone being sexy which I
shouldn't have been because I was also
watching the Golden Girls and
celebrating their wild times and when my
own Nana was trying to tell me what
makes her a horny I shut her down and
that's not very nice
so anyway
I always think of my Nana that time of
year and there was one year when she was
let's see
she died at 99 when I was 35 so if I was
15 that would have made her 79 yeah
about 79 but this makes sense I was a
bad teenager now it's probably little
older because I think I was I was about
18 so she's probably her early 80s she
says um I went on antidepressants and
she told the family that at Thanksgiving
dinner and we were like why are you
depressed she goes I can't stop living
and I thought that was the funniest
thing and oh my god I am so mad
at myself oh my god I have the most
genius ending to a joke I just
taped on my Netflix special I could
never find an ending god damn it this is
what happens Jesus Christ are
you kidding me it's not that good it
just it's not that good it's just a lot
okay my home Netflix specialist called
just keep living because it's Matthew
McConaughey's personal mantra and I have
it tattooed on my ankle
JKL and the whole point ah it's
just a logic thing you guys will watch a
special and you'll love it anyway but
what I'm saying is I tell a story about
my friend's grandfather who's in the
Holocaust and she was inspired by
historian she got his name tattooed on
her wrist and I say no one in my family
ever said anything inspiring I had to
read a People magazine and tattoo
something Matthew McConaughey said on my
ankle just keep living and so I go on
and on and it's a fine little quick joke
story but what I'm about to tell you
you'll go oh well that's the punchline -
you're joking - special and I'll go
shudder Ben didn't come to me so
whatever I tell you as we said Nana so
oh my god it would have gone so okay we
said Nana why are you on antidepressants
and she said I just can't seem to stop
living and we're like oh and she's like
it's freaking me out being alive was
freaking her out because she thought God
was keeping her on earth because he
didn't want her around him and so she
thought the longer she lived the closer
that have definitely meant she was going
to hell and she was like just send me to
hell just get it over with
and she would always so she would take
her pill and she would look at me and go
I can't stop living and just smile at me
how the did I not think to put that
in my joke that my friend would sit and
listen to her 80 something-year-old
grandfather was like I survived the
Holocaust and she was all inspired and I
got a talk of my grandmother going I
can't stop living it's time to start
taking pills that story lives in my
brain that lives in my soul
god dammit this is what happens when
your comedian and you got new hour every
year you a new hour every year you
gotta take it anyway just know that that
would have been a better ending to the
joke but that's what she said I can't
stop living and she'd take her
oh not Prozac what's the other one that
was very popular Zoloft and she would
start drinking wine and Moop that was
fun she would have a glass or two I mean
say Nana are you supposed to be drinking
you know obviously everyone on
antidepressants drinks but she's no lady
and she was like whatever if it gets me
there sooner meaning death and then she
would get very Randy as you would say
and she would say she loved playing
cards shoved gambling she's a big
gambler loved with the slot machines we
don't have a slot machine in my family's
home and she would say let's play poker
and I didn't know how to play poker and
she would be like you're crazy you got
to know how to play poker
and so he cleared the table and then she
would start flirting with my dad not her
son so it's not as weird and she would
go let's play strip poker Ronny and he'd
be like okay Jeannette I don't know
about dad all right
and then he'd start losing and she'd go
come on Ronny strip and then she would
just sit on his lap and I have a great
picture of her just jumping into his lap
she had to start acting like Courtney
Love she'd just get in his lap and just
start like putting her arms around him
and just being like wow and it was so
much fun and I don't know why that woman
wanted to stop living because she was a
real trip and most of the time she was
just very quiet and very sweet and
reading the Enquirer and I love a love
Nana in Jeanette but I always think of
her around Thanksgiving oh and the
favorite thing that she used to love to
do that my mother
and she used to love to annoy my mother
as though she was my mother's child not
my mother's mother you know eat those
taper candles we had those and my sister
taught me how to run your finger through
the flame without it catching on fire
and my Nana would love when we would do
that and we would teach her my min ago
stop teaching Nana how to put a hand in
the flame and she can catch on fire
easier like old people
their skin maybe it's true her skin did
look like paper but she got oh stop it
Joanne your mother's no fun and then my
mother would cry and be like stop
ganging up on me with my own mother and
just the memories don't stop the
memories of Thanksgivings don't stop and
so family is important this time of year
and I really do miss miss my Nana's she
was oh she was great I feel I feel she
would not have voted for Donald Trump I
feel she would have been like what a
stupid she I remember she
screamed when she was 90 I hate the
Yankees and I'm a Democrat and she
wasn't losing her mind she just felt
passionate and screamed that out one day
and you have to understand when you're
she worked in the Lowell mills the mills
of Lowell the textile mills you know
bosses grabbing her but making 5 cents a
year turned horrendous conditions and
she I was talking to a young guy it was
like a young 25 year old guy I go my
Nana never wanted to get married you
know she wanted to be a seamstress and
she was actually 28 when she got married
and this guy goes why'd she get married
I'm like Oh
facepalm dude it was 1928 women
have no money you dumb weren't you
married I mean don't be stupid
don't be stupid it's Howard Stern's
father said to him don't be stupid you
so anyway I said well she kind of
had to well I'm like no no well no well
she had to so god bless you Nana I hope
there is a heaven I hope Jesus is there
I hope God's not mad at you wish it was
right what we just dismissed people who
say crazy what if she was right
like if she was like well I haven't gone
to church in a while because I don't
have my normal ride and I don't drive
she never learned how her husband
wouldn't let her why wouldn't you just
drive on a Raymond shut up so any
what God is like that like a was let's
just pretend there's a god and assume
there's a God I don't mean pretend like
there isn't I have no answer and I'm
fine with it either way but let's say
there's a God and we don't get bogged
down in a if there's a God argument we
just for this story there's one and
we're all down here like no he's so nice
he's just you know and forgiving and and
then my Nana as her knees get bad can't
walk to church anymore doesn't have a
ride and has no car and God's like do
you see this Jesus get over here my only
son come here look at this who the
yeah she's watching a on the
family reruns getting all hopped up for
this for this guy meathead she could be
in church right now I should have gone
with that guy that took her to
McDonald's but gia was to him
this I want her up here I
don't want her up here I'm gonna keep
her alive 20 more years like what if
that was God starting to think it is so
anyway
oh can i all right before I read the
listener emails and then we get the
out of here I'm gonna talk about my I
don't normally do this I shouldn't do it
it's gonna talk about a family member
who made a comment on install do it I'll
do it
um I won't say who it is I have a family
member who is the sweetest woman you
have ever known she is she reminds me of
my other grandmother my Nana Kirkman
banana Kirkman um when we found out she
had Alzheimer's we were like wait you're
just finding out now like she seemed
like she was like she was forgetful in
that Alzheimer's waste and she was 60
you know so maybe she had a really onset
we didn't know but um when she had it to
like hallucination levels and didn't
know who people was we're in her 90s
like she was kind of like that anyway
for a long time but the one thing about
my Nana was she had a hard life and I
didn't really find out about some things
until after she died that um she thought
her husband was cheating on her because
he was and one night she just wasn't
home when he came home to UM get his
dinner that was cooked and she had taken
a job as a waitress down the street
somewhere
and basically was like if you want to
see me for dinner you can come sit and
take the kids and I'll wait on here I
mean it was such a classic story but
anyway I didn't know this about her I
didn't know that she was one of those
silent strong types that would do things
like that and just you know if her
husband was cheating
he stays in her life she never says
anything but she kind of got a little of
her own independence that's not the
story my point is she was always a big
Jesus lover
Jesus Mary statues everywhere maybe I'm
romanticizing or I didn't really ask her
hey are you racist or homophobic but it
doesn't seem that way she was not like
all there enough in a way to even have
too deep of an opinion on things like
she loved angels and her cats and Jesus
and it wasn't an ax brimstone and fire
way it wasn't this Bible Belt way it was
just like Jesus seems like a nice man
and Jesus forgives and always be nice to
each other
and that's all she talked about and so
there's a family member that's related
to her who is the same way and she's
lovely and she really walks the walk of
someone who loves JC and she's no
stranger to people of different races
with people of different races and our
family by marriage and stuff and I
assumed she was probably a little
socially conservative but not in the way
that it wouldn't infringe on anyone else
if that made sense she'd probably be the
type to welcome anyone who's gay into
the fold but maybe secretly she would
worry they were going to hell which I'm
not saying is a great way to be but it's
it's pretty good for someone that could
be worse if that makes sense anyway
Shay I posted a picture of a swastika on
my Instagram account before you go what
the did you do that for it was a
picture of a tweet that he senator had
posted who found one carved outside of
his home in New York City and he had
written in the tweet that this was a
direct result of Trump's America and
there'd been 700 hate crimes in the last
day and so I put that on my Instagram
as in this is very sad and how scary and
it's New York City my old home I don't
like to see New York City acting that
way uh and she has never commented on my
Instagram before there's pictures of my
Christmas tree there's pictures of me
doing things that are fun and lively and
she wrote don't blame Trump for this and
I thought oh she's not doing critical
intellectual thinking where I didn't say
Trump got on the mic and said paint
swastikas but he didn't denounce any of
the hate crimes and he hired Steve
Bannon who is a literal Nazi and his
whole campaign was one of hatred and so
she's correct I only heard him talking
about Muslims and Mexicans but I assumed
we would extend the same courtesy of
hatred to the Jews if you're a trump
supporter who actively enjoyed his
message of separation and I found it
interesting that she had to be so
literal and say blame the person who did
it and I'm thinking okay honey that's a
very adorable message but when we talk
about a culture that someone created
that's what it stems down from and I'm
sure that person was anti-semitic for
years but now they feel emboldened by
that because their president doesn't
give a and is not uniting America
is letting it divide itself and again
you know me I'm fine with us dividing
let all the racist punks try to run
their own country but anyway I was very
hurt and I wrote back that I was hurt
and I deleted the comment that I just
deleted the post and I'm not going to my
family's extended Christmas extended
family's Christmas party this year I
wasn't anyway but it really brought home
to me
that it's not just my loudmouth members
of my family who loved trumpets everyone
and it's silent and it's very upsetting
and so I don't know how she can look at
her kids and her mixed-race
grandchildren and say yeah I'm voting
against you I don't know how and if she
wants to think that she wasn't if she
wants to think that she is not complicit
that's great but I'm done with the
and I think she's lovely and
nice and that's why I never want to do
anything to hurt her
but I disagree violently with her I
think she was out on
with me and I would love to know if
anyone in my family if anyone didn't
vote for Trump I'd love to hear from you
because I really it's so far it's just
me and my two sisters that didn't and
God god I can't imagine if I didn't have
sisters like I did I can't imagine I'm
so thankful thankful for my sister's
such lovely lovely women I mean that the
sweetest like to a fault care about
other people where I'm like you guys
come on let's get selfish I love my
sister's shoutout to them okay listen
her emails I said send me fucked-up
things about Thanksgiving and this one
this one broke my heart I don't know I
don't know if you guys remember last
year an older woman wrote me that she
loves hallmark movies just like I do
hang on I forget when we were
corresponding me if it was on Instagram
or Twitter I might have even been Gmail
or her son I don't remember it I talked
to so many of you people know I know I
said I'd love to watch one with you
sometime and I'm serious but now I'm
boiling water so she writes hi Jen it's
Judy your adoptive 75 year old grandma
who loves hallmark movies the season has
begun
I've already started watching and my son
told me you're having a special viewing
with your fans of your favorite hallmark
boy would I love to be there and that's
the truth thank you for reading my other
letter on your podcast and I hope we can
watch one together someday I love silver
bells and fallen angel have a wonderful
holiday season
best wishes judy judy i love you i love
you even if you voted for Trump Judy I
love you and do to your son or your
grandson I know your son is making it
sound as though I'm watching hallmark
movies and inviting people over and
you're not invited I don't know what
he's talking about so far I've only
watched them by myself I don't even make
my significant other watch them because
we I've showed him like five minutes he
gets he gets the point
i watch them over text with my sister
Gail I can't get my other sister into it
she's busy saving the world which I mean
that not as a pejorative it's a good
thing but I'm not having any such thing
the only thing I can think of that he
might be thinking of is my Jen Kirkman
dysfunctional Christmas show December
3rd at the Hollywood improv where
instead of doing a traditional stand-up
I'm gonna do 10 minutes where I sort of
poke fun at the production quality of
the hallmark movies that might be what
he's talking about so you know as you
know Judi when you love something deeply
that's when you can parody it and I love
those movies deeply but I'm noticing
this season they all have a common
thread as they always do the busy
businesswoman doesn't have time for love
is holding cups of coffee with no liquid
in the cups and they're like here's your
hot coffee and the person just grabs it
with like one finger and like twirls it
like a you know Globetrotter and
I'm like why don't they act like there's
coffee in the cup it's not that hard to
do you can put water in it you know and
things like that and all the usual
tropes that we enjoy now you're naming
movies I don't know silver bells and
fallen angel Judi are we watching
there's two hallmark channel's there's
hallmark and then there's like hm and or
something so there's two kinds of
hallmark movies one is they're always
romantic it's busy businesswoman New
York City really filmed in Toronto she
doesn't have time for love she goes
outside a lot with her no scarf no hat
no gloves it's snowing and then she
meets some guy and then they fall in
love and then she gets both things a job
she gets a promotion they're always with
men that don't have jobs and then she
gets a promotion and then he works with
her and then they I don't know live
happily ever after
but then there's ones that are more
about angels and divorced moms and
someone died so I'm wondering if you're
watching the more like I called them the
more like religious heavy message ones
I'll have to watch those
okay this is from I didn't write down
their name dear Jen trying to keep this
brief thank you a few years ago our
usual big family Thanksgiving turned
into a small one that included four
people I've never met before the day
before I had grapes with lunch and it
felt like one was stuck in my esophagus
I spent four hours in the ER that night
before they decided either nothing was
there
or at least it wasn't serious enough to
call in a specialist to look at it on
holiday the feeling went away at some
point on Thanksgiving and I later
learned about the globus sensation which
is the feeling of having a lump in your
throat frequently due to anxiety like
the anxiety and I seem fun listener
might get about having to spend
Thanksgiving with strangers the end that
is true and you know when I was having
my vocal problems two doctors told me it
was in my head and I was having blob a
sensation and I was like I don't feel
like there's a lump in my throat
you can hear my vocal cords aren't
working and I can feel a strain and like
a soreness in my throat which turned out
to be as a reflux so mm-hmm I do know
about globus Globus some cares
that sounds like a horrible Thanksgiving
um so this Australian says I have my
first Thanksgiving five years ago I'm
Australian so we don't celebrate it
however I was living in Shanghai China
at the time and most of my friends were
Americans we celebrated the holiday
thoughts eating a giant bird that takes
hours to cook as disgusting
having it presented the way it is is
awful oh I agree my friends had to
prepare their turkey in their bathtub
once because it was so large is this
normal I don't think so you know me I'm
a vegetarian and anyone bitching about
the environment you got to be a
vegetarian you can't
the combination of marshmallow and sweet
potato is heavenly yeah that's a thing I
never had in my family that was like I
heard about other people make them must
be rich Brussels sprouts why does
someone every year bring brussel sprouts
I never had those growing up now I like
them sorry what the is this actual
holiday celebrating well I just read you
the thing when will white people learn
never do people protest this holiday
nope surely they must we don't
by the way you know that this is a
hundred percent the live left loved
lady's favorite holiday and you know
she's been planning her menu table
setting and all and knitting fall
sweaters for everyone in the family in
four months that's true but she doesn't
have time to yell at you right now about
that because she's busy working in her
cubicle
I bought Thanksgiving napkins don't get
me wrong it's a turkey with little
glasses he looks kind of like a nerd
Turkey which I'm not into nerd culture
unknown there are the only Thanksgiving
napkins I could find at Cost Plus World
Market my favorite place they should
totally advertise on the podcast don't
you think get cost-plus on the
phone or just tell them to send me
um I think that's it okay I'm gonna make
a plea right now to everybody out there
I hope this was a good Thanksgiving
episode I think it was perfect a little
depressing a little fun he saw me have a
meltdown about thinking of a good ending
to a joke um my book I just wish I had
it on me
my book I can barely take care of myself
tales of a happy life without kids is
the perfect Christmas gift
for you or your friend that doesn't want
kids now that book came out three years
ago and since then a lot of books about
not having kids have come out and
everyone references them like it's so
funny I'm like I wrote one of the first
ones so go back to the source my other
book I know what I'm doing another lies
I tell myself but traveling by myself
bores living by my own drum beat that is
a great gift for the individual in your
family or to give someone who doesn't
understand you your individualism and
say read this and you'll get to know me
both books are on amazon.com both are in
paperback no the both are in hardcover
the one about no kids I can barely take
care of myself is in paperback they're
both on Kindle for like $9.99 come on
people so uh I would encourage you to
think about those books as Christmas
gifts I know that 85% of the icing
funders did not buy my book the first
week like I asked you to so I am gonna
ask you now to buy it if you still
haven't bought it as a Christmas gift
for you and yours I also just got
verified today on Instagram so you can
all go yourselves
I'm officially too good to do this
podcast and this is my last episode just
kidding just kidding that's how I'm
gonna say I'm gonna be in New York next
week doing something at Joe's Pub for
the IFC Network so if you see me going
to New York don't be like who things to
do tour was over it's a television
taping it's a little comedy sketch I
have to do calm the down I'm only
gonna be in New York for 30 hours so no
I'm not doing any other shows when I'm
there I will just be flying in flying
out I will be in New York the 9th
through the 14th um for vacation because
that's how I do so again don't be like
oh no I actually friends there that I
want to see and spending time because I
met my main man in New York at Christmas
which sounds like a hallmark movie and
it basically was and so we'll be going
there to do Christmasy things so if you
see any of that on my Instagram
please prevent me the heart attack and
don't go who doing shows no if I do it's
like I'll pop in to a friend's show and
do five minutes but I don't really have
time all my nights are booked so don't
get on my ass all right that's about it
enjoy enjoy your holidays I know at this
position American episode of forgot that
there's not Thanksgiving other places
but um I I think of I think of all of
you and I look at this and I'm so great
oh my god I'm so thankful that I seem
fun audience you guys have been so nice
to me lately the things you've been
writing on the Facebook wall and on the
Twitter it's just been you're such
sweethearts I feel such love I feel if
we can be nice to each other we don't
know each other there's such hope for
the world there's goodness out there you
guys I still don't know if I'm gonna do
this week seemed fun this week I think
I'm gonna give myself a week off but
I'll be back in the swing of things next
week or I might tape one and then just
have it for next week because I'm gonna
be so busy but uh let me just get the
you know all the different
at at icing fund podcast on Twitter and
the Facebook page is FB dot M e /i
seemed fun podcast and you know what
it's been a while go to itunes give it
five stars and write I can't stop living
as your review how's that sound um
otherwise that's it until next week have
fun